-Our next guest is a six-time
Grammy Award-winning
singer and songwriter.
Her #1 "New York Times"
best-selling memoir,
"Broken Horses,"
is now available
as an audiobook.
Please welcome back to the show
Brandi Carlile.
How are you, Brandi?
-I'm good. How are you, Seth?
-I am wonderful.
It is very strange in these days
to Zoom with our guests,
but it does provide guests to be
in very interesting places.
And you are joining us,
is it true, from a fishing trip?
-I am. I'm in a very remote
fishing village
up in the peninsula
in Washington State.
-And is this something
that you planned to do
knowing it was
when your book was coming out?
-I mean, I just celebrated my
#1 "New York Times" best-seller
by staying in a $39 motel room
in a fishing village.
Yeah. Check it out. Look.
-Oh, it's beautiful.
Oh, that's so --
[ Laughter ]
You must --
You must get me the information.
-And I got --
I'm all geared up to go.
-[ Laughs ]
It's so -- It's so rare
that we talk to someone
who has a knife on their belt.
-Yeah, I know. I just thought
you might like that.
-Also, I think if you thought
we're going to have
a "New York Times"
not just best-selling author,
#1 best-selling author,
I think if you thought that,
you might unfairly assume
they wouldn't have
a knife with them.
And I think that speaks to how
many different boxes you tick.
-Well, thank you.
Thank you very much.
-[ Laughs ]
Now, I actually want to show --
We actually have a video of you,
the exact moment you found out
you were #1 on the "New York
Times" best-seller list.
Let's take a look.
-You're the #1
"New York Times" best-seller.
-No!
One?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Number one?
-Yes.
-What?!
-[ Laughs ]
No!
[ Both laugh ]
Oh [bleep]
-Congratulations.
It's a --
It's a really cool thing.
And I have to ask, you know,
when you write something
like this --
And look, it's not like your
music isn't personal, either.
But this is, you know --
This isn't metaphor.
It's not, you know,
distant from who you are.
It's very personal.
How does it feel to, one,
share it with people,
and then have it
so well-received?
-Oh, I mean, it was scary then,
and it's scary now.
And you're right.
That's the main difference.
You can write these songs,
and you're shrouded
in metaphor and analogy
and all these different things.
And that's like --
It just doesn't --
That's not what comes out
when you write a book.
You know? I mean, I sat down
to start writing it,
and about five weeks later,
I realized it wasn't going
to fit into a 3 1/2 minute song.
And, you know, I had to sort of
strip away all that metaphor.
And it's -- It was --
It's always going to be
a little scary, I think.
It was well received
by -- by folks,
which has made me feel --
I just said "folks"
like the joke earlier,
but hopefully everybody
understands what that means.
[ Both laugh ]
It's just that
it's life-affirming.
That's what it is.
It's life-affirming.
-I wonder how it feels to --
Because you recorded
the audiobook.
So obviously, you write a book.
And I'm sure you rewrite
and rewrite,
and then it gets locked,
and it's a book.
And then you have to go
and read it out loud.
Did that -- Was that a other
totally different journey,
doing that part?
-It was fun doing it,
but I will never listen to it.
I can't listen to the sound
of my own voice.
And I don't know how you do it.
It's like --
Doesn't it sound different
in your head
than it sounds
when you say it out loud?
-Yes. But I should note
that I'm like you.
I don't particularly
like hearing it back.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I think -- I feel like
it's this very full --
It's this very full
and strong voice.
And then I watch, and I'm like,
"Whoa, it's really --
It's very nasally."
[ Both laugh ]
-You do have a full,
strong voice.
I actually quite like listening
to myself sing, though.
-You do?
Well, that's nice to hear.
Do you recommend --
Do you ever --
When you're with a group
of friends, do you ever say,
"Hey, we should
throw on some me"?
-Yeah, I'm like,
"You know, why not me?
Let's just --
Let's get in the car
and just do me this road trip."
[ Both laugh ]
-Do most of the people
you hang with,
are they amenable
to that suggestion?
-Well, they laugh at me.
-Right.
-You know? Sure, you know.
And I'm like, I have this --
a healthy self-esteem
about my singing voice,
and I like listening to me,
which is good,
because no one else
in my family does.
-That's heartbreaking,
'cause you -- I know you have --
You have two daughters.
And they do not enjoy
listening to you.
-One loves John Denver.
-Uh-huh.
-And the other one loves
the "Frozen" soundtrack
so kind of typical.
Really cliché.
-Right.
-Really cliché kids.
-You have a lot of --
And you speak to, I should say,
a lot of your influences
in this book, from Elton John
to Tanya Tucker to your mom.
Did you --
Over the course of your career
as you developed your own voice,
were you acutely aware
of how those influences
were finding their way
into your music?
-I think like most young people,
I started out
just mimicking
with a lot of affectation.
And I'm not sure affectation
really falls away.
I just think you diversify
who influences you
to the point where
so many people influence you
that it's hard to pinpoint
any one person.
But, you know,
you can see it on --
in this audiobook,
where I recorded 31 songs.
And like you said, they're,
like, wildly diverse.
And all of these people
are my heroes
and have been my heroes,
you know,
in a more concentrated way
at different points in my life.
And I think
during points of my life,
I mimicked all those people.
And now it's just mixing,
a melting pot of it.
-And now, of course,
due to your success,
there are going to be singers,
and there are singers
working right now
who you can tell have been
influenced by Brandi Carlile.
Do you have an ear for that,
and is that something
that you are flattered by?
-Yeah. I see it more,
more and more as I get older.
And I just --
I'm getting ready to turn 40.
And I'm like "You know, I really
like that that's happening."
'Cause I'm that kind of girl.
I do heroes.
I have heroes.
You know, that's how I am.
And the thought that maybe
I could influence a young person
or, you know,
be of service in that way,
it's cool when I hear
a young girl sing,
and she's got some nuance
that sounds like my voice,
or she's wearing,
you know, a hat
like the one I wear
every single day or something.
I'm like, "Well, maybe
I'm actually changing things
to a certain extent
a little, tiny bit."
And I love it. And I hope so,
'cause certainly,
a lot of people have changed me.
-You talk about your mom
in the book a great deal.
And you have a wild, wild story
where for not
a short amount of time,
she suspected that your dad
was a serial killer.
-Oh, yeah, the Green River
Killer, actually.
Yeah, where we grew up,
the Green River Killer
was like the bogeyman,
just destroyed
all these '80s childhoods,
because he was just, like,
this awful thing
that was in the news
all the time.
And my dad and mom,
they kind of just got married
right after they met
'cause they --
They were pregnant with me.
And so my mom
didn't know him that well.
And he would always go fishing,
you know,
at 4:00 in the morning,
5:00 in the morning
to catch first light.
So, I'm, like, in my 20s,
years down the road,
and I read a book about it,
and I was like talking to my mom
like, "Man, Dad looked just like
that Green River Killer fella
they got," you know.
And she goes, "Do you want
to talk about this right now?"
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"That's so creepy.
What are you talking about?"
She's like, "For three years,
I thought your father
was the Green River Killer.
I almost went to the task force
and turned him in."
I'm like,
"And you just continued
to raise us in that house?"
Yeah, that should
tell you everything
about how eccentric and dark
and funny my --
-It's so funny to think, like,
"Well [Sighs] do I go
to the task force?
It's just -- That's going
to be a whole thing."
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
"No, that's a whole thing.
I'm just going to ride this out
and see how it goes."
-"I'll just ride it,
see how it breaks."
Hey, will you be out --
I know it's -- You're like
three hours earlier than us.
Are you done fishing
for the day?
'Cause I know that's
an early, early thing to do.
-No, I got out this morning,
and it was a little foggy.
I couldn't see too far ahead
of me, so I just went locally.
But today, I'm a go ahead
and motor out for a couple hours
and go get after some lingcod.
-Alright.
Well, I hope
they're biting for you.
It's really lovely to see you,
as always.
And do please come back soon.
-I will.
It's lovely to see you, too.
Thanks for having me on.
I'm so excited.
-Of course.
"Broken Horses" is now available
as an audiobook.